the argument this morning in case 0 8
2:05 Citizens United vs. the Federal
Election Committee Commission mr. Olson
mr. Chief Justice and may it please the
court
robust debate about candidates for
elective office is the most fundamental
value protected by the First Amendment's
guarantee of free speech yet that is
precisely the dialogue that the
government has prohibited if practiced
by unions or corporations any union or
any corporation the government claims it
may do so based upon the austin decision
that corporate speech is by its nature
corrosive and distorting because it
might not reflect actual public support
for the views expressed by the
corporation the government admits that
that radical concept of requiring public
support for the speech before you can
speak would even authorize it to
criminalize books and signs this court
needs no reminding that the government
when it is acting to prohibit
particularly when is acting to
criminalize speech that is at the very
core of the First Amendment
has a heavy burden to prove that there
is a compelling governmental interest
that judge that justifies that
prohibition and that the regulation
adopted in this case a criminal statute
is the most narrowly tailored necessary
to accomplish that compelling
governmental interest mr. Olson are you
taking the position that there is no
difference in the First Amendment rights
of an individual a corporation after all
is not endowed by its creator with
inalienable rights so is there any
distinction that Congress could draw
between corporations and natural human
beings for purposes of campaign finance
what the court has said in the First
Amendment context New York Times versus
Sullivan
Grosse Jean versus Associated Press and
over and over again as at corporations
are persons entitled to protection under
the First Amendment nowadays yes would
that include today's mega corporations
where many of the investors may be
foreign individuals or entities the
court in the past has made no
distinction based upon the nature of the
entity that might own a share of a
corporation owned many shares pardon um
nowadays there are foreign interests
even foreign governments that own not
one share but a goodly number of shares
I submit that the Court's decisions in
connection with the First Amendment and
corporations have in the past made no
such distinction
in your view and the interview that
you're putting forth that there is no
distinction between an individual and
corporation for First Amendment purposes
than any mega corporation even even if
most of the investors are from abroad a
Congress could not limit their spend not
I'm not saying that Justice Ginsburg I'm
saying that the First Amendment applies
then the next step is to determine
whether Congress and the government has
established a compelling governmental
interest and a narrowly tailored remedy
to that interest if the Congress and
there's no record of that in this case
of which I'm aware certainly the
government has not advanced it in its
briefs that there is some compelling
governmental interest because of foreign
investment in corporations if there was
then the court would look at determine
how serious is that interest how
destructive has it been to the process
and whether the maybe the limitation
would have something to do with the
ownership of shares of a corporation or
do you think Congress could prevent
foreign individuals from funding speech
in United States elections the private
individuals foreigners who one of the
that's of course a different question I
haven't studied it Justice Scalia but
everybody asked it because I thought it
was related the fundamental point here
is and let me start with this and I
think we should we should start with
this and the government hardly mentions
this the language and universal element
we shall make mr. Olson which answer
Justice Ginsburg said the question yes
or no
can the label a decide foreign investors
can look at the cans as the First
Amendment permit any distinction between
corporate speakers and individual
speakers I have not I'm not aware of a
case that just asking it I mean in your
view does it permit at this thing my
view is based upon the decisions of this
court and my view would be that unless
there is a compelling governmental
interest and a narrowly if there is a
compelling government can there be any
case in which is the different treatment
of corporations in individuals and I
would not rule that out justice Stevens
I mean there may be I can't imagine all
of the infinite varieties of potential
problems that might exist but but we
would eventually come back to the narrow
tailoring problem anyway what the
government has done here is prohibit
speech I don't know how many unions are
in this country but there are something
like 6 million corporations that filed
tax returns in 2006 mr. Olson do you
think that media corporations that are
owned or principally owned by foreign
shareholders have less First Amendment
rights than other media corporations in
the United States I don't think so um
Justice Alito and certainly there's no
record to suggest that there is any kind
of problem based upon that and I come
back to the language of the First
Amendment Congress shall make no law now
what this Court has repeatedly said is
that there may be laws inhibiting speech
if there's a compelling governmental
interest and a narrowly tailored remedy
but there is no justification for this I
was going to say that 97 percent of the
6 million corporations that filed tax
returns in 2006 had assets less than 5
million dollars assets not net worth so
we're talking about a prohibition that
covers every corporation in the United
States include
nonprofit corporations limited liability
corporation subchapter S corporations
and every union any night what is the
you use the word prohibition mr. Olsen
one answer to that is that no entity is
being prohibited that it's a question of
not whether corporations can contribute
but how they can use PACs and that way
we assure that the people who contribute
are really supportive of the issue of
the candidate but so the corporation can
give but it has to use a PAC I
respectfully disagree the corporation
may not expend money it might find
people stockholders or officers who
wanted to contribute to a separate fund
who could then speak that one to use the
words of one justice that's
ventriloquist speak I would say there's
more like surrogate speech if you can
find some other people that will say
what you want to say and get them to
contribute money through a process that
this justice is with you I mean you that
you those are the directors the CEO not
the shareholders we don't know what they
think
well this statute is not limited to
cases where the shareholders agree or
disagree with what the corporation says
as the court said in the bellotti case
the prohibition would exist whether or
not the shareholders agreed but let me
go back to your question it covers
totally totally owned corporations too
doesn't it yes and we've eye on all the
stock in the corporation our
corporations go camp yes and it includes
membership corporations such as Citizens
United that the individual contribution
also covers people who'd like to give
twenty five hundred dollars instead of
twenty four hundred which is the limit
and maybe there are a hundred million or
two hundred million people in the United
States who if they gave twenty five
hundred rather than 24 hundred nobody
could say that that was really an effort
to buy the senator the congressman
so is that unconstitutional - no well
what this court has said
that in connection with contribution
limitations there is a potential
compelling governmental interest this is
what Buckley says you know then that and
that but expenditures which is what
we're talking about today do not concern
that the question or the actual threat
of quid pro quo corruption or the
appearance of good Pro corruption and
you know Justice Breyer what the court
said in that case is because it's not
inhibiting someone from actually
speaking it's it's giving this out here
the obvious argument is look they said
the compelling interest is that people
think that representatives are being
bought okay that's to put it in a power
caricature but you know understand what
I'm driving at okay that's what they say
in Buckley v Valeo so Congress now says
precisely that interest leads us to want
to limit the expenditures that
corporations can make on electioneering
communication in the last 30 days of a
primary over-the-air television but not
on radio not on books not on
I don't pamphlets not on anything else
right so in what respect is there not
conceptual at least a compelling
interest and narrow tailoring well in
the first place I accept what the court
said in Buckley that expenditures do not
raise that concern at all Congress has
not made that finding you're talking and
you mentioned just just just a matter of
radio and television but in Buckley
versus Valeo the court specifically said
that that is the most important means of
communicating the election and the court
used the words indispensable so what and
and what the court said in Buckley
versus Valeo is it compared a limitation
on expenditures independent
uncoordinated expenditures with the
prohibition that the court addressed
when it had a statute before that said
newspapers couldn't endorse candidates
on the day of election and the Tornillo
case were required a right of reply to
be given and the court said those
restrictions which were unconstitutional
were considerably less and that the
restriction in Buckley versus Valeo on
expenditures I agree
I agree that Buckley made the
distinction between contributions and
expenditures and it seems to me that the
government's argument necessarily wants
to water down that distinction but in
response or just in furtherance of
justice Breyers point you have two cases
one in which a office holder goes to a
corporation says will you please give me
money they said we can't do that the
other is in which a corporation takes
out an ad for the for the candidate
which we leaves that candidate of the
responsibility of substantial television
coverage under isn't that about the same
well in the first place if there's any
coordination and I think Buckley says no
but but it is a tactical matter is that
always true well it may not always be
true the in the infinite potential
applications of something like that
Justice Kennedy anything might possibly
be true and Justice Breyer said well
what if Congress thought or what if
Congress thought the people might think
that that was kind of somehow suspect
that is not a basis for prohibiting
speech by a whole class of ended was a
basis or prohibiting a speech by in the
sense of giving contributions above
twenty four hundred dollars by three
hundred million people in the United
States but the point which I think is
the one Justice Kennedy was picking up
is are we arguing here between you and
my questions is the argument in this
case about the existence of a compelling
interest because Congress seemed to
think that there was certainly that it's
this concern about the perception that
people are say buying candidates are we
arguing about narrow tailoring Congress
thought it was narrow tailoring or are
we arguing about whether we should
second-guess Congress on whether there
is enough of a compelling interest and
the tailoring is narrow enough you must
hours second-guess Congress when the
First Amendment is in play and we're
arguing we're not we're discussing
yes both of compelling both of
compelling governmental interest and the
narrow tailoring and what the what there
is not a sufficient record the reason
the government has shifted position here
they were first of all talking about the
so-called distortion rationale in Austin
the distortion rationale which they
seemed to have abandoned in the in the
supplemental briefs filed in connection
with this argument and they resorted to
the corruption appearance of corruption
there isn't a sufficient record of this
there is what about the district courts
finding wasn't there a finding before
the three-judge court that federal
officials know of and feel indebted to
corporations or unions who financed ads
urging their election or the defeat of
their opponent there was a finding of
fact to that effect was there not the
fight yes I there is something to that
effect in the district court opinion but
it doesn't cover all corporations it
didn't focus in specifically on if they
discovered large corporations so you
take out the mom-and-pop single
shareholder well that's ninety seven
percent of the corporation not ninety
seven percent of the contributions I
mean the contributions that count are
the ones from the corporations that can
amass these huge sums in their
Treasuries
I think that goes back to Justice
Kennedy's question and my response which
distinguishes between contributions and
expenditures the point that Justice
Kennedy was making in his question is
that under some circumstances and
expenditure might coincide or resonate
with what the candidate wishes to do but
the court looked at that very carefully
in buckley versus vallejo and said that
might not be the case that might in fact
be these expenditures might be
counterproductive when they're
independent they're not coordinated with
the candidate they are more directly
expression by the party spending the
money they're not like a contribution so
they're more of an
entrenchment on the right to speak and
they are less of a threat of corruption
because there is less there's no quid
pro quo there and if there is it would
be punishable as a crime Council in your
discussion of austin you rely on its
inconsistency with pilate
the faladi of course involved a
referendum austin expenditures in an
individual election why isn't that a
significant distinction well it is a
just is that what the pilate court said
is that we're not deciding that question
and and austin did address you're
correct
um expenditures but it based it on a
rationale more than said we're not
deciding it said they're entirely
different situations you read that long
footnote in which has been cited six or
eight times by our later cases yes and
i've also read the footnote 14 in the
Bilotti case that cited case after case
after case that said corporations had
rights or protected rights under the
First Amendment
I'm not disagreeing with what you just
said justice Stevens the court said it
was it would it was dicta on because the
Court did not deal with it it's been
repeated that footnote has been
repeatedly cited in subsequent cases
most of which were unanimous well
because it was and I agree that the
Pilate court was not discussing that but
the bellotti court always discuss it
precisely in that foot and it wasn't
said it's a different case I understand
and I don't disagree with what you've
just said justice Stevens you say it
come out differently it just said we're
not deciding yes Daddy that is that's
the point I'm trying I don't mind citing
that what what a lot II didn't decide
that what pilate also said is and i
think that this is also in many
decisions of this court the inherent
worth of speech in terms of its capacity
for informing the public does not depend
upon the identity of the source whether
corporation association union or
individual now that how that we've
cleared up that Bilotti didn't decide
the question what what is the
distinction that
why don't you think that distinction
makes sense in other words a corporate
you don't have the potential for
corruption if a corporation is simply
speaking on a referendum that may
directly affect its interest if you're
dealing with a candidate what the court
has said in the past is that you do have
that problem of corruption in other
words why isn't that distinction a way
to reconcile their Lobby in Austin there
is a distinction but I think the
distinction goes back to a expenditures
versus contributions number one and then
secondly it goes back to what this court
said in conjunction with the
impossibility of finding a distinction
between issue ads and candidate ads the
line dissolves on practical application
the interest of upgrated we say that you
said that repeatedly including most
recently in the Wisconsin Right to Life
case um and and it's the first appeared
in Buckley itself the distinction is
very hard to draw between the interest
that the speaker is addressing and
whether it's a candidate or issue
because issues are wrapped up in
candidates the corporation interest and
the interest that its fiduciary officers
are representing when it speaks on
behalf of the corporation they don't get
here correct to say the court said there
was no distinction that said the
distinction requires the use of magic
words and that's what they said in
Wisconsin Right to Life water both of
them said there is a distinction well
but the words are difficult to draw in
some cases but nobody said there's no
distinction that I'm aware well what the
court do you to use the words of the
Court which occurred repeatedly is that
the distinction dissolves in practical
application that justice Stevens I think
addresses the very common-sense point
that when you're addressing an issue
whether you're addressing a referendum
matter whether it's a proposed
legislation or a candidate that is going
to raise taxes on the corporation those
distinctions dissolve it's all First
Amendment freedom I thought that Buckley
had narrowed the statute precisely to
magic words and still found it
unconstitutional as applied to
corporations that made independent
expenditures in
what happened in Buckley the thousand
dollar limit in Buckley was first of all
limited to the magic words
um candidacy um expression then secondly
the court and an end up and the storage
of the statute were any person which
included corporations found a statute as
narrowed unconstitutional and said and
some of the plaintiffs were corporations
some of the plaintiffs were corporations
animal and the DA's discussed in the
opinion was it it wasn't discussed in
the opinion but was this discussed in
the opinion was the breadth of the
definition of person which did include
corporation corporations were parties in
the case and in that part of the Buckley
case the court repeatedly cites cases
involving corporations including
n-double-a-cp versus Alabama and New
York Times versus Sullivan all cases
involving corporations so while it
wasn't specifically discussed it was a
part of the decision of the court that
$1,000 limitation was worse more
restrictive than the restriction of
editorials appearing on Election Day or
requiring a newspaper to give a right of
reply the court in Buckley in fact says
this is with respect to that expenditure
limitation the words of the court were
this is the most drastic of the
limitations imposed by the federal
election campaign Act it goes to the
core of First Amendment freedom if
that's so this is a point that is
concerning I don't know the answer
precisely but suppose you're right
suppose we overrule these two cases
would that leave the country in a
situation where corporations and trade
unions can spend as much as they want in
the last 30 days on television ads etc
of this kind but political parties
couldn't because political parties can
only spend hard money on this kind of
expenditure and therefore the group that
is charged with the responsibility of
building a platform that will appeal to
a majority of Americans is limited but
the in the groups that have particular
interests like corporations or trade
unions and spend as much as they want am
i right about the consequence if I'm
right what do we do a
I think you're wrong about the
consequence there are 27 states that
have no limitations on either
contributions or expenditures and that
the earth has not no I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm saying am i right in thinking if
you win the political party can't spend
this money it's limited to hard money
contributions but corporations and trade
unions can spend unlimited funds well if
if the court decides in favor of the
arguments that we are making here I
think what you're suggesting is that
because there are other limitations that
someone has not challenged in this case
that that would be somehow unfair and
unbalanced adjusting that I am
suggesting will make a hash of this
statute and if we're going to make a
hash of the statute what do we do about
it and that's why I want you to take a
position on another important part of
that statute and that is the part that
says political parties themselves cannot
make these expenditures that we're
talking about except out of hard money
what I want to address that in this way
and I said when we were here before the
most fundamental right that we can
exercise in a democracy under the First
Amendment is dialogue and communication
about political candidates we have
enrapt
wrapped up that freedom smothered that
freedom with the most complicated set of
regulations and bureaucratic controls
last year the Federal Election
Commission that was supposed to be able
to give advisory opinions didn't even
have a quorum for six months of the year
2008 when people would have needed some
help from the Federal Election
Commission what I'm saying in answer to
your question Justice Breyer there are I
suspect all kinds of problems with
federal election laws where they apply
to parties and where they apply to what
candidates might do and so forth but
that has never been a justification we
will uphold a prohibition on all kinds
of people speaking because we allowed
them to speak someone else might
complain that they don't get to speak as
much as they would like with reference
to any
on gorilla tees that might flow from our
adopting your position are you aware of
any case in this court which says that
we must refrain from addressing an
unconstitutional aspect of the statute
because the statute is flawed in some
other respects as well no I'm not and
that's I think that was what I was
attempting to say in response to what
Justice Breyer was asking me mr. Olson
are you giving up on your earlier
arguments that there are ways to avoid
the constitutional question to resolve
this case I know that we asked for
further briefing on on this particular
issue of overturning two of our Court's
precedents but are you giving up on your
earlier arguments that there are
statutory interpretations that would
avoid the constitutional question no
justice Sotomayor what what there are
all kinds of lines that the court could
draw which would provide a victory to my
client there are so many reasons why the
federal government did not have the
right to criminalize this 90-minute
documentary that had to do with
elections but what what the court
addressed specifically in the Washington
right-to-life case is that the lines if
they are to be drawn must be not be
lines that in that are ambiguous that
invite litigation that hold the threat
of prosecution over an individual and in
practical application that is what Missy
Olson my difficulty is but you make very
impassioned arguments about why this is
a bad system the courts have developed
in its jurisprudence but we don't have
any record developed below you make a
lot of arguments about how far and the
nature of corporations single
corporation single stockholder
corporations etc but there's no record
that I'm reviewing that actually goes in
to the very question that you're you're
arguing exists which is a patchwork of
regulatory and jurisprudential
guidelines that are so unclear there I
would like to answer that there are
several answers to it and I'd like to
reserve the balance
my time for rebuttal it is the
government has has the burden to prove
the record that justifies telling
someone that wants to make a 90 minute
documentary about a candidate for
president that they will go to jail if
they broadcast it the government has the
obligation and the government had a long
legislative record and plenty of
opportunity to produce that record and
it's their obligation to do so it's like
I asked one question you can answer on
rebuttal
no one has commented on the National
Right Rifle Association's amicus brief
no no none of the litigants have its
written response to justice Sotomayor
thought that there are narrow ways of
resolving the problem before us on
rebuttal will you tell us what your
review on their solution to this problem
is I will Justice thanks for why don't
you tell us now we'll give you a time
for rebuttal don't keep us in suspense
every every line including the lines
that would be drawn in several of the
amicus briefs and they're not the same
could put the entity who wishes to speak
before you again
a year from now because the movie might
be shorter it might be video on demand
it might be a broadcast it might have a
different tone with respect to a
candidate every one of those lines puts
the speaker at peril that he will go to
jail or be prosecuted or there will be
litigation all of which chills speech
and inhibits intuitive to answer my
question the line suggested by the NRA
is the line identified by Congress in
the snow Jeffords amendment dealing with
individual financing of speech which
would separate all of these problems
what is your comment on that possible
solution to I would I would like to take
advantage of justice Stevens offer and
and respond to that during the rebuttal
mr. chief justice
Thank You mr. Olsen mr. Abrams mr. Chief
Justice and may it please the court
the first case cited to you by mr. Olson
haven't any New York Times against
Sullivan and I'd like to begin by urging
two propositions on you from that case
in that case the court was confronted
with a situation where the times made
three arguments to the court they said
for us to win they said you either have
to revise basically federalized libel
law to a considerable degree by which
they did or they said we only sold 390
copies in Alabama so you could rule in
our favor by saying there was no
jurisdiction or they said we didn't even
mention sheriff Sullivan's name so you
could rule in our favor on the ground
that they haven't proved a libel case
the court did the first it did the first
which is the broader rather than the
narrowest way to address the question
and I suspect they did it don't know but
I suspect they did it because they had
come to the conclusion that the degree
of First Amendment danger by the sort of
lawsuits which were occurring in Alabama
at elsewhere was something that had to
be faced up to by the court now or
Abrams the Times against Sullivan was
not did not involve overruling
precedents of this court that have been
followed by this court and others so I
think the situation true your honor they
did it did involve overruling 150 years
of American jurisprudence I mean there
there was no law at that
and that says there's no total power
this court I mean we got straight into
adhere to our pressing especially a case
like Austin which was repeating the
business about amassing large funds in
corporate Treasuries was not a new idea
in Austin and it was repeated after
after Austin but there was so Times
against Sullivan I think is quite
distinct of the question that was posed
here is is it a proper way to resolve
this case to overrule one precedent in
flow on another in part and what I'm
urging on you your honor is that by a
parity of reasoning although not
precisely the same situation that there
are cases in which there is a an ongoing
threat to freedom of expression which
may lead if you were to agree to that
which may lead the court to say rather
than taking a narrower route to the same
result it is worth our moving away in
this case from looking for the narrowest
way out and and determining it now
rather than the next as-applied
challenge there are two separate
questions that that have been raised in
opposition to your position one is one
is that we should not resolve a broad
constitutional issue where there are
narrower grounds and that's the question
in responding to an entirely separate
question is the issue of stare decisis
yes and you you acknowledge that stare
decisis wasn't involved in New York
Times versus our on what the first
question obviously was right and start
decisis of course as a question much
much briefed by the parties and it it is
one which involves of course a
consideration not only of the merits of
the decision but certain other factors
the length of time the decision has been
in a
and the life the time in this case for
the McConnell case of course is only six
years the time for the Austin cases
nineteen years which is less than one
ruling of this court just last term but
what the court said in Austin it also
said in the N RWC case which was I think
eight years before Austin so Austin was
not a new invention well Austin was the
first time that corporate speech was bar
corporate independent expenditures were
barred by a ruling of this court that
have not happened prior to Austin and
the Solicitor General's brief
acknowledged is that no but they have
been limits on corporate spending in aid
of a political campaign since the turn
of the 20th century that there had been
limits on corporate contributions since
to the turn of the century corporate
independent expenditures came much later
and that's something that that I think
is worth later in 1947 yes your honor
1947 President Truman vetoed that bill
saying that it was a dangerous intrusion
into free speech that has always been an
area of enormous controversy not just in
the public sphere but in the judicial
sphere the early cases of AB
taft-hartley were ones in which what the
court did was to basically say in one
case after another that the statute did
not govern the particular facts of the
case so as to avoid there was a reunion
cases weren't they rather than quit yes
there that they they were three Union
cases and the case after that
essentially was buckling and and buckley
held unconstitutional the limits posed
there to independent expenditures all
I'm saying is that it this is not a
situation as if we have an unbroken
amount of years throughout American
history in which it has been acts
accepted that independent expenditures
could be bored it has always been a
matter of high level of controversy with
with courts at first and understandably
shying away from facing up to the issue
directly and then the first ruling on
point
have you read was reckless dissent in
the bloody case Ontario
have you read justice rehnquist dissent
in the blood yes yeah-ha-ha which is
somewhat inconsistent with what you said
it is and also inconsistent with his
later view correct right at Jeff's
desperate going back to the question of
starry decisis the one thing that is
very interesting about this area of law
for the last 100 years is the active
involvement of both state and federal
legislatures in trying to find that
balance between the interests of
protecting in their views how the
electoral process should proceed and the
interest of the First Amendment and so
my question to you is once we say they
can't accept on the basis of a
compelling government interest narrowly
tailored are we cutting off where would
we be cutting off that future democratic
process because what you are suggesting
is that the courts who created
corporations as persons a birth to
corporations as persons and there could
be an argument made that that was the
courts error to start with not Austin or
McConnell but the fact that the courts
imbued a creature of state law with
human characteristics within we can go
back to the very basics that way well
but wouldn't we be doing some more harm
than good by a broad ruling in a case
that doesn't involve for business
corporations
and actually doesn't even involve the
traditional nonprofit corporation it
involves an advocacy corporation that
has a very particular interest Your
Honor I don't think you'd be doing more
harm than good
in vindicating the First Amendment
rights here which transcend that of
citizens united I mean I think reading
my friend's brief on the right they come
some of them these come pretty close to
saying there must be a way for citizens
united to win this case other than a
broad way in my view the principles at
stake here are the same citizens united
have this to be a sort of a paradigmatic
example of the sort of group speaking no
less about who to who to vote for not
who to vote for what to think about a
potential ongoing candidate for
president of the United States but but
in lots of other situations
day by day there is a a block to public
discourse caused as a result of this
congressional legislation and and so we
think it is not a matter of cutting off
what legislators can do they can still
pass legislation doing all sorts of
things they could do public funding they
could do many other things that don't
violate the First Amendment if we're
right and saying that independent
expenditures that category of money
leading to speech that we're talking
about today if we're right that that is
the sort of speech which is at the core
of the First Amendment then you would be
doing only good only good by ruling that
way today across the board back in your
honor thank you mr. Abrams
general Kagan mr. Chief Justice and may
it please the court I have three very
quick points to make about the
government's position the first is that
this issue has a long history for over a
hundred years Congress has made a
judgment the corporation's must be
subject to special rules when they
participate in elections and this Court
has never questioned that judgemental
number two wait wait wait wait wait we
never questioned it but we never
approved it either and and we gave some
really weird interpretations to the
taft-hartley Act in order to avoid
confronting the question I'll repeat
what I said Justice Scalia for a hundred
years this court faced with many
opportunities to do so left standing the
legislation that is at issue in this
case first the contribution limits then
the expenditure limits that came in by
way of taft-hartley and then of course
in in Austin specifically approved those
limits I don't understand what you're
saying I mean we're we're we're not a
self self-starting institution here we
only disapprove of something when
somebody asks us to and if there was no
occasion for us to approve or disapprove
it proves nothing whatever that we
didn't disapprove it well you're not a
self-starting institution but many
litigants brought many cases to you 1907
onwards and in each case this court
turns down declined the opportunity to
invalidate or otherwise interfere with
this legislation but that judgment was
validated the Buckley's contribution
expenditure line and you're correct if
you look at contributions but this is an
expenditure case and I think that it
doesn't clarify the situation to say
that 400 years to suggest it for a
hundred years we would have allowed
expenditure limitations which in order
to work at all
have to have a speaker based distinction
exemption for medium content-based
distinction
time-based distinction we've never
allowed that well I think justice
Stevens was right in saying that the
expenditure limits
that are in play in this case came into
effect in 1947 so it's been 60 years
rather than a hundred years but in fact
even before that the contribution limits
were thought to include independent
expenditures and as soon as Congress saw
independent expenditures going on
Congress closed what it perceived to be
illegal so in fact for a hundred years
corporations have made neither
contributions nor expenditures save for
a brief period of time in the middle of
1940s which Congress very swiftly
reacted to by passing the taft-hartley
Act now the reason that Congress has
enacted these special rules and this is
the second point that I wanted to make
before you go to your second point may I
ask you to clarify one part of the first
namely your answer to the question I
proposed to just to mr. Olson namely why
isn't this no Jeffords amendment which
was picked on by Congress itself an
approach which is argued by the NRA an
appropriate answer to this case that was
my third point justice Stevens I'm sorry
so we'll just skip over the second
my third point is that this is an
anomalous case in part because this is
an atypical plaintiff and the reason
this is an atypical plaintiff is because
this plaintiff is an ideological
nonprofit so you're giving up you're
setting up the distinction from MCFL
that you defended in your opening brief
there you said this doesn't qualify as a
different kind of corporation because it
takes corporate funds and now you're
changing that position no I don't think
we're changing it MCFL is the law and
the FDA FEC has always tried to
implement MCFL faithfully and that's
what the FEC has tried to do but if you
know I guess but do you think MCFL
applies in this case even though the
corporation takes a core corporate funds
from for-profit corporations
I don't think EPS MCFL as written
applies in this case but I think that
the court could as lower courts have
done adjust MCFL potentially to make it
apply in this case although I think that
that would require a remand what lower
courts have done MCFL was set up it was
written in a very strict kind of way so
that the organization had to have a
policy of accepting no corporate funds
whatsoever
some of the lower courts including the
DC Circuit which of course seized a lot
of these cases have suggested that MCFL
is too strict that it doesn't you do you
think it's too strict I the FEC has no
objection to MCFL being adjusted in
order to give it some flexibility what
the you want to give up this case change
your position and basically say you lose
solely because the questioning that
we've directed on rhe argument solely
because I'm sorry because of the
question we posed on we argument no I
don't think that that's fair we think we
continue to think that the judgment
below should be affirmed if you're
asking me mr. Chief Justice as to
whether the government has a preference
as to the way in which it loses if it
has to lose
the problem faced of ours what case of
ours suggests that there's a hierarchy
of bases on which we should rule against
a party when both of them involve
constitutional questions extending
modifying MCFL would be I assume by
virtue of the first amendment overruling
Austin would be by virtue of the first
amendment so what case says we should
prefer one as opposed to the other I
think the question really is the courts
standard practice of deciding as-applied
challenges before facial challenges in
this case certainly raises a number of
tricky as-applied questions one is the
question of how the the statute applies
to nonprofit organizations such as this
one another is the question of how it
applies to VOD transmissions yet another
is the question of how it applies to a
90-minute infomercial as opposed to
smaller advertisements but if you if you
insist on as the as-applied challenge
isn't that inconsistent with the whole
line of cases that began in Thornhill
versus Alabama and cokes versus
Cincinnati what about the Thornhill
doctrine is not cited in the brief but
that doctrine is that even if a litigant
without standing a to object to a
particular form of conduct can raise
that if the statute covers it in order
that the statute does not have an
ongoing chill against speech and there's
no place where an ongoing show is more
dangerous than in the elections context
I think you're you're asking us to have
an ongoing chill where we have
as-applied challenges which are based on
as I indicated for speaker content time
and this is the kind of chilling effect
that the Thornhill doctrine stands
directly against you know I think even
in the First Amendment context Justice
Kennedy the court will not strike down a
statute on its face unless it finds a
very substantial overbreadth many
applications of the statute that are
unconstitutional as opposed to just a
few or just some what I'm suggesting
here is that the court was right in
McConnell and then confirmed in W rtl to
find that get grow which is of course
the only statute
directly involved in this case did not
have that substantial over breath let me
ask you this suppose that we were to
rule that nonprofit corporations could
not be covered by the statute
would that but the statute then had
substantial overbreadth well I would
urge you not to do that in that kind of
sweeping way because the the reason for
the nonprofit corporations being covered
is to make sure that the nonprofit
corporations don't function as conduits
for the for-profit corporation suppose
we were to say that with the statute
then not be substantially overbroad
well I don't think that the statute is
substantially over broad right now so if
you took out certain applications I
can't see asking you to assume that we
draw the non profit profit distinction
then the statute it seems to me clearly
has to fall because number one we
couldn't sever it based on the language
I see what you're saying well you could
do a couple of things you could do what
justice Stevens suggested so justice
Stevens suggested I suggested to Chief
Justice I don't think you really caught
what I suggested because you treated it
as an enlargement of the MCF Alec said I
was going to go back that is not but the
National Rifle Association argues or
what's a no Jeffords go
it covers ads that are financed
exclusively by individuals even though
they are sponsored by a corporation yes
that's exactly right what you're
suggesting justice Stevens is
essentially stripping the Wellstone
amendment from bit reciprocity while
treating this no Jeffords amendment as
being the correct test and nobody's
explained why that wouldn't be a proper
solution
not nearly as drastic is is being argued
yes and there are some you know there
are some reasons that that might that
might be appropriate the Wellstone
amendment was a funny kind of thing that
was passed very narrowly but beyond that
it was passed with a pretty substantial
support of many people who voted against
the legislation in the end presumably as
a poison pill if we go to if we go that
rude what we're doing is creating an
accounting industry aren't we
corporations give huge amounts of money
to the c-4 organization and then
somebody perhaps the FEC has to decide
whether in fact that's a way of
subverting the prohibition against the
direct payment for the camp at for the
communication right
okay so Congress said we don't want that
Congress said that's going to be a
nightmare and we decide Wellstone or
whatever reasons now don't we have to
focus on whether Congress can say that
or whether it can't but kinda nice
little white in the hand that's saying
Congress also said if you strike down
the Wellstone amendment we want this no
Jeffords amande that's true why
shouldn't we follow that correct if you
strike down the Wilson amendment what is
left is the snow Jeffords environment
which allows nonprofit organizations of
the kind here to fund these ads out of
separate bank accounts not packs just
separate bank accounts which include
only individual expenditure why is that
not the wisest narrow solution of the
problem before well it is it is
certainly a narrower and I think better
solution than a facial invalidation of
the whole statute council what do you
what do you understand to be the
compelling interest that court
articulated in Austin I think that what
the court articulated in Austin and of
course in the the government briefs
we've suggested that Austin did not
articulate what we believe to be the
strongest compelling interest which is
the anti-corruption interest but what
the court articulated in Austin was
essentially a concern about corporations
using the corporate form to appropriate
other people's money for express right
so but you you've more or less abandoned
is too strong a word but as you say
you've relied on a different interest
the quid pro quo corruption and you want
you articulate in page 11 of your brief
you recognize that this Court has not
accepted that interest as a compelling
interest so isn't it the case that as
you view Austin it's kind of up for play
in the sense that you would grow
founded on an interest that the court
has never recognized well a couple of
points the first thing is as you say we
have not abandon Austin we have simply
said that in addition to where other
people's money interest that we're in
your we're in your supplemental briefing
do you say that this aggregation of
wealth interest supports Austin it would
not really call it an aggregation of
wealth interest I would say that it's
it's a concern about corporate use of
other people's money to election putting
it outside putting the quid pro Interest
aside where in your supplemental
briefing do you support the interest
that was articulated by the court in
Austin where we talk about shareholder
protection and where we talk about the
distortion of the electoral process that
occurs when corporations use their
shareholders money who may or may not
understand that to be a different
interest that's the shareholder
protection interest as opposed to the
fact corporations have such wealth and
they distort the marketplace well I
think that they're connected because
both Connor so am i right and in saying
in the supplemental briefing you do not
rely at all the market distortion
rationale on which Austin relied not the
shareholder rationale not the quid pro
quo rationale the market distortion
issue these corporations have a lot of
money we did not rely at all on Austin
to the extent that anybody takes Austin
to be suggesting anything about the
equalization of a speech market so I
know that that's the way many people
understand the distortion rationale of
Austin and if that's the way the court
understands that we do not rely at all
on that so if we have to preserve if we
are going to preserve Austin we have to
accept your invitation that the quid pro
quo interest supports the holding bear
or the shareholder protection interest I
would say either the quid pro quo
interest but the corruption interest or
the shareholder interest or what I would
say is a is something related to the
shareholder interest that is in truth my
view of Austin which is a view that when
corporations use other people's money to
election-year that is a harm not just to
the shareholders themselves but a sort
of broader core harm to the public that
comes from Distortion
of the electioneering that's done spice
corporation let's talk about overbreadth
you-you-you said let's assume that that
is a valid interest what percentage of
the total number of corporations in the
country are not single shareholder
corporations the local hairdresser the
local auto repair shop the the local a
new car dealer I don't know any small
business in this country that isn't
incorporated and the vast majority of
them are sole shareholder owned now this
statute makes it unlawful for all of
them to do the things that you're
worried about you know distorting other
the interests of other shareholders that
is vast overbreadth
you know I think that the single
shareholders can present these
corruption problems many many closed
corporations single shareholder
corporations I'm not talking about the
corruption interest you you you have
your quid pro quo argument that's
another one when we get to that when we
get there but but as far as the interest
you're now addressing which is those
shareholders who don't agree with this
political position are being somehow
cheated it doesn't apply probably to the
vast majority of corporations in this
country you're quite right Justice
Scalia the when we when it comes to
single shareholders that the kind of
other people's money interests the
shareholder protection interests do not
apply well that can't be the
justification but their strongest
justification is the anti-corruption
intro with respect to that what is your
answer to the argument that more than
half the states including California and
Oregon Virginia Washington state
Delaware Maryland great many others
permit independent corporate
expenditures for just these purposes now
have they all been overwhelmed by
corruption a lot of money is spent on
Elections in California as is there a
record that the corporation's have
corrupted the political process there
yeah I think the experience of some half
the state
it's cannot be more important than the
hundred-year-old judgment of Congress
that these expenditures would corrupt
the federal system and I think that
their Congress has a self-interest I
mean we we are suspicious of
congressional action in the First
Amendment area precisely because we are
at least I am I doubt that one can
expect a body of incumbents to draw
election restrictions that do not favor
incumbents now is that excessively
cynical of me I don't think so I think
Justice Scalia it's wrong in fact
corporate and union money go
overwhelmingly to incumbents this may be
the single most self-denying thing that
Congress has ever done if you look if
you look at the last election cycle and
look at corporate PAC money and ask
where it goes it goes ten times more to
incumbent than to challengers and in the
prior election cycle even more than that
and for an obvious reason because when
corporations play in the political
process they want winners they want
people who will produce outcomes for
them and they know that the way to get
those outcomes the way to get those
winners is to invest in incumbents and
so that's what they do as I said in
double digits times more than they
invest in challengers so I think that
that that that rationale which is
undoubtedly true in many contexts simply
it's not the case with respect to you
under your position if a corporation's a
B and C are called to Washington every
Monday morning by a high-ranking
administrative official or a
high-ranking member of the Congress with
with a committee chairmanship and and
told to toe the line and to tell their
directors and their shareholders with
the policy ought to be some other
corporation can't object to that during
the election cycle the government
silences a corporate objector and those
corporations may have the most knowledge
of this on the subject corporations have
lots of knowledge about environment
transportation issues and your silence
in them during the election well when
other corporations by your by them and
because of the very fact you just point
out I've already been used and are being
used by the government to express its
views and you say another corporation
can't objective it well to the extent
Justice Kennedy that you're talking
about what goes on in the halls of
Congress of course corporations can
lobby members of Congress in the same
way that they could afford this
legislation but this legislation is
designed to do because of this
anti-corruption interest is to make sure
that that lobbying is just persuasion
and it's not coercion but in addition to
that of course corporations have many
opportunities to speak outside the halls
of Congress one of the amicus briefs
objects responds to Justice Kennedy's
problem by saying the problem is we've
got to contribute to both parties and a
lot of them do don't they
a lot of them do which is a suggestion
about how corporations engage the
political process and how corporations
are different from individuals in this
respect you know an individual can be
the wealthiest person in the world but
few of us maybe some but few of us are
only our economic interests we have
beliefs we have convictions we have
likes and dislikes corporations engage
the political process an entirely
different way and this is what makes
them so much more damaged well that's
not I'm sorry but that seems rather odd
a large corporation just like an
individual has many diverse interests
the corporation may want to support a
particular candidate but they may be
concerned just as you say about what
their shareholders are going to think
about that they may be concerned that
their shareholders would rather they
spend their money doing something else
the idea that corporations just are
different than individuals in that
respect I just don't think holds up well
all I was suggesting mr. Chief Justice
is that corporations have actually a
fiduciary obligation to their
shareholders to increase value that's
their single purpose their goal so if a
candidate take a tobacco company and a
candidates running on the platform that
they ought to make tobacco illegal
presumably that company would maximize
its shareholders interests by opposing
the election of that individual but
everything is geared through the
corporation's self-interest in order to
maximize
prophets in order to maximize revenue in
order to maximize value individuals are
more complicated than that so that when
corporations engage the political
process they do it with that set of you
know blinders what I don't mean to be
pejorative because that's what we want
corporations to do is zero some do but
let's say if you have ten individuals
and they each contribute a thousand
dollars to a corporation and they say we
want this corporation to convey a
particular message why can't they do
that what if they did that as a
partnership it would be alright well
it's it sounds to me as though the
corporation that you're describing is
the corporation of a kind that we have
in this case where one can assume that
the members all sign on to the
corporation's ideological mission where
the corporation in fact has an
ideological mission general Kagan most
most corporations are indistinguishable
from the individual who owns them the
local hairdresser the new auto dealers
who has just lost his dealership and and
who wants to oppose whatever congressman
he thinks was responsible for this
happening or whatever congressman won't
try to patch it up by by by getting the
the auto company to undo it
there is no distinction between the
individual interests and the corporate
interest and that is true for the vast
majority of corporations what yet this
law freezes all of them out you know to
the extent that we're only talking about
single shareholder corporations I guess
I would ask why it's any burden on that
single shareholder to make the
expenditures to participate in the
political process and the way that
person wants to outside the corporate
forum so single shareholders aren't
aren't suffering any burden here they
can do everything that they could within
the corporate form outside the corporate
form they probably don't get the tax
break that they would get inside the
corporate form but I'm not sure anything
else is very different oh he wants to
put up the sign well providers would
take care of about 90 percent of the
smaller corporations that Justice
Scalia's dog in law
they can't choose it they can't even
give money to charity sometimes but
of ultra vires giving political account
revision is not typical corporate
activity is I remember spending quite a
few days one summer reading through a
thousand pages of opinion in the DC
Circuit and I came away with the
distinct impression that Congress has
built an enormous record of support for
this bill in the evidence and my
recollection is but it's now a couple of
years old that there was a lot of
information in that which suggested that
many millions of voters think at the
least that large corporate and union
expenditures or contributions in favor
of a candidate lead the benefited
political figure to decide why
specifically in favor of the
contributing or expending organization
the corporation of the Union yes that
how it was on the basis of that I think
that this Court upheld the law in Fikret
but we've heard from the other side
there isn't much of a record on this so
I've you can save me some time here
perhaps you could point me if I'm right
to those thousand pages of opinion and
tens of thousands of underlying bits of
evidence where there might be support
for that proposition yes that's exactly
right Justice Breyer that in addition to
just the hundred-year-old judgment the
Congress believes this is necessary that
very recently members of Congress and
others created a gigantic record showing
that there was corruption and that there
was the appearance of corruption and in
that record many times
senators former senators talked about
the way in which fundraising is at the
front of their mind and everything that
they do the way in which they grant
access the way in which they grant
influence and the way in which outcomes
likely change as a result of that fund
and down to size it seems to your
shareholder protection rationale isn't
it extraordinarily paternalistic for the
government to take the position that
shareholders are too stupid to keep
track of what their corporations are
doing and
can't sell their shares or object in the
corporate context if they don't like it
I don't think so mr. chief justice I
mean I for one can't keep track of but
mine where I hold well you have a busy
job
you can't expect ordinary I mean the the
idea and as I understand the rationale
is we we the government Big Brother has
to protect shareholders from themselves
they might give money they might buy
shares and a corporation and they don't
know that the corporation is taking out
radio ads the government has to keep an
eye on their entry I appreciate that
it's not that I have a busy job it's
that I like most Americans own shares
through mutual funds you don't know
where your mutual funds are investing so
you don't know where so it is I mean I
understand so it is a paternalistic
interest we the government have to
protect you naive shareholders in a
world in which most people own stock
through mutual funds in a world in which
most people own stock through retirement
plans in which they have to invest they
have no choice I think it's very
difficult for individual shareholders to
be able to monitor what each company
they own assets in is doing or even to
know the extent of the doing that in
that respect it's unlike the Union
because the the worker does not want to
affiliate with Union cannot have funds
from his own pocket
devoted to political causes but there's
no comparable check for corporation
that's exactly right Justice Ginsburg in
the Union context of course it's a
constitutional right that the unions
give back essentially the funds that any
union member employee in the workplace
does not want used for electoral
purposes does that mean that you need to
be taken out because there isn't the
same and the shareholder protection
interest doesn't there's no parallel for
the Union you're right about that but
the government believes that with
respect to unions the anti-corruption
interest is as strong and that unions
should be kept in
I think what your point suggests the the
the union member point suggests why
Congress might have thought that there
was a compelling interest to protect
corporate shareholders in the same way
that lets say dissent in union members
are protected by the Constitution
there's no state action of course so
there's no constitutional right in the
corporate context but Congress made a
judgment that it was an important value
that shareholders have this choice have
the ability both to invest in our
country's assets and also to be able to
choose our country's leaders it's not
investing in our countries in the course
of this argument have you have you
covered point two I very much know what
it is like my note sir they very much
appreciate that does this Kennedy I
think I did cover point two which was an
explication of some of the questions
that the Chief Justice asked me about
what interests the government was
suggesting motivated these laws and are
compelling enough such that this court
certainly should not invalidate these
laws I take it we have never accepted
your shareholder protection interest
this is a new argument you know I think
that that's fair a certainly bellotti
does not accept it I would say you know
national rights to work is an
interesting opinion because national
right to work accepts for a unanimous
Court both the shareholder protection
argument and the anti-corruption
argument with respect to section 441b
in particular now in later cases the
court has suggested that national right
to work was only focused on
contributions if you read a national
right to work that distinction really
does not it's not evident on the face of
the opinion and I think Chief Justice
Rehnquist and later in a later dissent
suggested that he had never understood
it that way but so National Right to
Work is is a confusion on this point and
I guess other than that and I think
there may be some ambiguity there but I
wouldn't say that an hour WC is a
holding on shareholder protection so to
the extent you've abandoned the original
ration
in Austin and articulated different
rationales you have to the quid pro quo
corruption interest and the shareholder
protection interest which we think I was
in Austin Austin I thought was based on
the aggregation of immense wealth by
corporations you know again listen is
not the most lucid opinion but the way
we understand Austin what Austin was
suggesting was that the corporate form
gave corporations significant assets
other people's money that when the
corporation's spent those at you can you
give me the citation of the page in
Austin where we accepted the shareholder
protection right it comes when the when
when the court is distinguishing MCFL
and the the message of that distinction
of MCFL is the shareholder protection
interest but did the words shareholder I
don't know do the words shareholder
protection appear in the Austin opinion
I honestly don't know mr. Chief Justice
and and but look I don't know they go
too far let's let's assume they don't
then I get back to my question which is
you are asking us to defend the Austin
or support or continue the Austin
opinion on the basis of two rationales
that we have never accepted shareholder
protection and quid pro quo corruption
well I would say on the quid pro quo
corruption of course you've accepted
that rationale in the context many
that's not an integer that's correct and
I think what has changed since since
that time is the bit were record that
Justice Breyer suggested which was very
strong on the notion that there was no
difference when it came to corporate
contributions and expenditures that
there actually was no difference between
the two that may be is that a yes is
that a yes in other words you're asking
us to uphold Austin on the basis of two
arguments two principles two compelling
interest we've never accepted in the in
expenditure in this particular context
fair enough you know I can undercut
Buckley and so doing well I don't think
so because I do think Buckley was about
individuals rather than corporations and
Buckley was in 1976 not in 2009 after
the
extensive record that was created in bit
row I see my time is up I don't mad or
just one one question that was
highlighted in the prior argument and
and that was if Congress could say no of
TV and radio ads could it also say no
newspaper ads no campaign biographies
last time the answer was yes Congress
could but it didn't is that is that
still the government's answer the
government's answer has changed Justice
Ginsburg it is still true the pick for
two or three which is the only statute
involved in this case does case does not
apply to books or anything other than
broadcast 441 B does on its face apply
to other media and we took what the
court what the courts the courts own
reaction to some of those hypotheticals
very seriously we went back we consider
the matter carefully and the
government's view is that although 441 B
does cover full-length books that there
would be a quite good as applied
challenge to any attempt to apply 441 B
in that context and I should say that
the FEC has never applied 441 B in that
context so for 60 years a book has never
been at issue what happened to the
overbreadth doctrine I mean I I thought
our doctrine in the Fourth Amendment is
if you write it too broadly you we're
not going to pare it back to the point
where it's constitutional if it's over
broad its invalid what happened to that
I don't think that it would be
substantially overbroad Justice Scalia
if I tell you that the FEC has never
applied this statute to a book to say
that it doesn't apply to books is to
take off you know essentially nothing
from you don't our our first we don't
put our First Amendment rights in the
hands of FEC bureaucrats and if you say
you're not going to apply it to a book
what about a pamphlet yeah I think
plant food would be different a pamphlet
is pretty classic electioneering so this
is no attempt to say that 441b only
applies to video and not to print what
does that particular what if the
particular movie involved here had not
been distributed and by video on demand
suppose that people could view it for
free on Netflix over the Internet
suppose that free DVDs were passed out
suppose people could attend the movie
for free in a movie theater suppose the
exact text of this was distributed in a
printed form now in light of your
retraction I have no idea where the
government would draw the line with
respect to the medium that could be
prohibited yes well none of those things
again are covered no but could they
which of them could in which could not I
understand you to say books could not
yes I think you what we're saying is
that there has never been an enforcement
action for books nobody has ever
suggested nobody in Congress nobody in
the administrative apparatus has ever
suggested that books pose any kind of
corruption problem so I think that there
would be a good as applied challenge
with respect to that so you're a lawyer
advising somebody who's about to come up
with a book and you say don't worry the
FCC the FEC has never tried to send
somebody to prison for this the statute
covers it but don't worry the FEC has
never done it that gonna comfort your
client I don't think so but this this
statute doesn't cover it doesn't cover
books no no that's exactly right the
only statute that's involved in this
case does not cover books so 441b which
does cover book which which which does
cover books except that i've just said
that there would be a good as applied
challenge and that there has been no
administrative practice of ever applying
extra books and also only applies to
express advocacy right 203 has is is has
a broader category of the functional
equivalent of Express advocacy but 441 B
is only Express advocacy which every
part of the reason why it's ever
or applied to a book I see one cannot
imagine very many books that would meet
the definition of Express advocacy as
this Court has understood I'm sorry that
we suggested some in the last argument
you have a history of union organizing
and Union involvement in the politics in
politics in the last sentence says in
light of all this vote for Jones I think
that that wouldn't be covered mr. chief
justice i the FEC is very careful and it
says this in all its regulations to view
matters as a whole and as a whole that
book would not count as Express advocacy
Thank You general
mr. Waxman mr. Chief Justice and may it
please the court
the requirement that corporations fund
electoral advocacy the same way
individuals do that is with money
voluntarily committed by people
associated with the corporation is
grounded in interests that are so
compelling that 52 years ago before
buckley was decided before fika was
enacted before buckley style quid pro
quo corruption was ever addressed this
Court explained that quote what is
involved here is the integrity of our
electoral process and not less the
responsibility of the individual citizen
for the successful functioning of that
process
if the court now wishes to reconsider
the existence and extent of the
interests that underlie that sentiment
expressed for the court by justice
frankfurter in the context of a
prosecution of Union officials for
running television ads supporting
political candidates it should do so in
a case in which those interests are
forthrightly challenged with a proper
and full record below one of the amicus
briefs I'm not maybe was Professor
Hayward if I'm getting that right
suggested the history of this nineteen
forty seven provision was such that it
really wasn't enforced because people
were concerned about the First Amendment
interest and that the courts to the
extent cases were brought did everything
they could to avoid enforcing the
limitations well I I don't recall who
the professor was either mr. chief
justice but I do recall pretty well the
history that was recounted I always say
the history that was recounted by this
court in the Auto Workers case in CIO
in the pipefitters case which is quite
inconsistent with that we've never had a
case until this Court's supplemental
order we've never had a case that
challenged directly quote Austin and
Austin style corruption which is a term
I think that is quite misleading when
the sober-minded LSU route was moved to
stand up in 1894 and urge the people of
the United States and urge the Congress
of the United States to enact
legislation that would address quote a
constantly growing evil which has done
more to shake the confidence of plain
people of small means of this country in
our political institutions than any
practice which has ever obtained since
the founding of our government he was
not engaging in a high-level discussion
about political philosophy but he was
talking about contributions in that
context as he declared I with all due
respect Justice Kennedy I don't think
that there was any distinction
whatsoever in that time between the
distinction that this court came to
understand as a result of fika and its
adjudication of figa and and that really
the prehistory of taft-hartley between
contribution expenditures for this
reason Justice Kennedy what route said
was the idea and I'm quoting now from
his speech which is also partly
reprinted in this court's opinion in
McConnell the idea is to prevent the
great companies the great aggregations
of wealth from using corporate funds
directly or indirectly to send members
of the legislature to these halls in
order to vote for their protection and
the advancement of their interests as
against those of the public great
allegations of wealth the briefed by the
Chamber of Commerce amicus brief by the
chamber of commerce points out that 96%
of its members employ less than a
hundred people these are not
aggregations of great wealth you're not
talking about the railroad barons and
the rapacious trusts of the llo who root
era you're talking mainly about small
business corporation Justice Scalia I
take your point and I think you have
made this point forcefully many times
before a unanimous Court and National
Right to Work committee it concluded
that Congress was entitled to make the
judgment that it would treat in order to
address this root evil a problem of such
concern that it goes to the very
foundation of the democratic-republican
exercise that is the notion of integrity
and representative government now this
this case of course is not a case that
but I don't understand that answer I
mean if that's what you're concerned
about what l who wrote was concerned
about you could have said all
corporations and you know have a net
worth of more than you know so much your
motive that doesn't Congress did it
ended all corporations right and Justice
Scalia if a small corporation or even
any corporation of any sort wants to
bring an as-applied challenge to 441b or
a state law analog and say you know I am
NOT the problem that Theodore Roosevelt
and Elihu root was addressed at there
isn't a compelling interest because I
only have three employees and $8,000 in
my bank account
that's fine but what is extraordinary
truly extraordinary given the sentiments
that underlay the Tillman act and the
taft-hartley Act is that we would be
having a discussion today about the
constitutionality of a law that has been
on the books forever when no party no
corporation has ever raised the
challenge well worth it's been on the
books forever
number number one the phenomenon of
television ads where we get information
about scientific discovery environment
transportation issues of from
corporations who have to all have
patents because they know something uh
that that is different and the history
you applied apply to contributions not
to those kinds of expenditures Justice
Kennedy first of all I think it is
actually true that patents are owned by
individuals and not corporations but be
that as it may there's no doubt I'm not
here saying that this Court should
reconsider Bilotti on first principles
any more than I'm saying that it
shouldn't consider Austin on first
principles corporations can and do speak
about a wide range of public policy
issues and since the controlling opinion
was issued in Wisconsin Right to Life
the the kind of campaign related speech
that corporations can't engage in in the
pre-election period is limited to the
functional equivalent of Express
advocacy and nothing else
mr. wax and Wallace talked about a
hundred years and 50 years is perplexing
it sounds like the sort of sound bites
that you hear on TV
the fact of the matter is that the only
cases that are being ricans that may
possibly be reconsidered are McConnell
and Austin and they don't go back 50
years and they don't go back 100 years
my point here is Justice Alito and I
don't mean to be to be demeaning this
court with sound bites the point is that
what Austin was to be sure the very
first case in which this court had to
decide actually had to decide whether or
not the prohibition on corporate
Treasury funded campaign speech could
properly be limited and was supporting
by a compelling interest
what I'm suggesting and I hope that if
you take nothing else from my advocacy
today it will be this is that we have
here a case in which the court has asked
a question that essentially goes to the
bona fide ins that is the factual
predicate of the interests that have
been viewed as compelling in Austin in
MCFL in McConnell itself whether you
call it the corrosive effect of
corporate wealth whether you call it
quote shareholder protection and my
point is that there is nothing unusual
whatsoever about a case in which a party
before the court says my constitutional
rights were violated and there is no
prior decision of this court holding
that what was done is constitutional and
in that situation is it an answer to
that argument that this has never been
challenged before the court has never
held that it was unconstitutional it has
been accepted up until this point by the
general public that this is that this is
a constitutional no that's not it
regarded as an answer to that but you
mr. Olson is was quite right was either
mr. Olson or mr. Abrams I find it so
difficult to tell them to apart one of
them was saying well it's you know yes
there I think in response to justice
Sotomayor his question you know about
well there's no factual record here
there's absolutely nothing in this case
and it's the response was well it's the
government's burden the government has
to prove that any restriction that it
imposes passes strict scrutiny fair
enough but the question has to be raised
the issue has to be raised if the if
Austin Justice Alito or the compelling
interests that Austin and McConnell
relied on were forthrightly challenged
in a case the government would have the
option is to Waxman the government did
have that opportunity and the government
compiled a record and when the citizens
united abandon that position you're
quite right they changed their course
the government and the district court
complained that it had to go to all this
work to develop this record and yet we
hear nothing
what the record showed well that's
because the own I assume I have your
permission answer my question but the
only challenges that were litigated in
the district court and they largely were
related to disclosure were very direct
as-applied challenges that had that did
nothing whatsoever to implicate the
foundation of McConnell or Austin and
all I'm saying is if you want to
reexamine the predicates the existence
and magnitude of interests that
Congress's going back a bit whether it's
sixty years or a hundred years and
courts whether it has been the actual
rationale of the decision or a predicate
of the rationale of the decision you
ought to do it in a case where the where
the issue is squarely presented so that
the government can do what it did in
McConnell and in another context in
Michigan versus brooder when it was
suggested that a Duran had undermined
this Court's controlling opinion in
Bakke thank you Thank You mr. Waxman
mr. Olson five minutes Thank You mr.
chief justice
the words I would leave with this court
are the Solicitor General's the
government's position has changed the
government's position has changed as to
what media might be covered by
congressional power to censor and banned
speech by corporations now we learn
contrary to what we heard in March that
books couldn't be prohibited but
pamphlets could be prohibited we also
learn if not the statute that we're
involved in in this case does not cover
those it unless they're engaged in quote
Express advocacy and the other way in
which the government has changed its
position if I listened carefully is what
type of corporation might be covered the
government now says that it wouldn't the
FEC is now willing to recede from its
regulations which explicitly covered
this corporation and I don't know as I
stand here today what kind of
corporations the
would choose to prosecute remember the
Federal Election Commission which didn't
even have a quorum and couldn't function
at all for six months during the
important election year of 2002 needs to
press only those who do not do not rely
exclusively on individual contribution
well that that's your question from
before yes justice Stevens and that a it
wouldn't this corporation accepted a
small amount two thousand dollars out of
out of the funding of this so that
wouldn't solve the problem for my
corporation my clients it would sell it
for the advertising there are two
different things is the the long Hilary
document and the advert advertisements
it would cover it but but they're the
only ones they're clearly violated my
point is that the overbreadth of this
statute that solves the problem by
saying that corporations still can't
speak and if you don't have anything to
do with them if they wear a scarlet
letter that says see if you accept one
dollar of funding and you better make
darn sure that when a check comes in for
a hundred dollars from the XYZ hardware
store in the neighborhood that it wasn't
the corporation that you used to make a
documentary about a candidate the other
way in which the government's position
has changed is we do not know as this
mean you disagree with the NRA
submission I submit that it does not
solve the problem that would lead
exactly if it solved the problem as it
would for the advertising it does it'd
be an appropriate look I can't say that
if it solved the problem because it
doesn't solve the problem of prohibiting
all corporate speech and I think and I'm
submitting justice Stevens and that's
unconstitutional I think what you're
suggesting is that some limitation that
what you're suggesting is not a whole
lot different than packet would lead I
think Justice Breyer was the same an
accounting nightmare or it would be
there's a nightmare that Congress
endorsed in the snow Jeffords well but
that but that the Wellstone amendment
sort of sense repealed and we've held
the Austin amendment literally cannot be
applied well we unanimously held I think
what would be my response is that that
does not solve the problem of inhibiting
of what so not in
the NRA's position we don't justice
Stevens and and as I said it wouldn't
exempt my clients the other the third
way in which the government's change
disposition is its rationale for this
prohibition in the first place is it
corruption is it shareholder protection
is it Equalization there was some
dispute
I heard the Solicitor General say that
the equalization rationale was something
the government disavowed it wasn't what
Austin said the government government
said and I if Marshall said that he was
not trying to equalize all voices in the
political process here's a sentence that
says among that's not what the rationale
of this case is I don't I don't with all
due respect Justice Ginsburg the words
that jump out at me are the words from
page 665 that say the desire to
counterbalance those advantages unique
to the corporate form is the state's
compelling interest in this case that
sounds to me like like Equalization I
don't know I'm I'm representing an
individual who wants to speak about
something that's the most important
thing that goes on in our democracy I'm
told it's a felony I'm not a now I don't
know what the rational basis is it's
over broad now I hear about this
shareholder protecting shareholders
there's not a word in the congressional
record with respect to the which was
before the court in the McConnell case
about protecting shareholders as the
baladi case pointed out that would be
over broad anyway because this statute
applies to every case I read that
sentence that you just read as meaning
the corporation is an artificial person
in respect to which the state creates
many abilities and capacities and the
state is free also to create some
disabilities and capacities it's not a
statement about balancing rich and poor
well if it strikes me that it is because
it follows the words that say
corporations are given unique advantages
to aggregate wealth and then we must
take away that advantage by equalizing
the process I think that's claim meaning
but my point I guess is if I may finish
the sentence briefly just my point is
that the government here has an
overbroad statute that covers
every corporation irrespective of what
its stockholders think irrespective of
whether it's big whether it's Joan a big
railroad baron or anything like that and
it doesn't know as it stands here today
two years after this movie was offered
for to the public for its view what
media might be covered what type of
corporation what might be covered and
what compelling justification or narrow
standard would be applied to this form
of speech Thank You counsel the case is
submitted
the Honorable Court is now adjourned
until Monday the 5th of October at 10:00
a.m.